resignation we're gonna watch the Super Mario
Brothers movie finally we did not see this
movie which I believe is the most successful
film of all time in the movie theaters just
so we can react to it with you here so you
guys are like you should support the movie
theaters billions of people already took care
of that for us we got a job to do John how
you doing Mamma Mia I'm excited are you excited
to catch every single Easter egg everyone
and know every obscure character's name guys
for every Easter egg we miss you make sure
to comment in the comment boxes below also
leave it a like that would be very much appreciated
I want to say a massive thank you to everyone
who has supported the reject Nation about
getting yourself a space baby's taste shirt
it is almost our number one most selling shirt
at shopzeroeddition.com I feel like it fits
in tuned animated Guardians you know is Chris
Pratt it all where it's it works it's connected
thank you guys Link in the description box
you want to go get yourself a space baby shirt
today oh yeah and lastly I want to say a special
thank you to everyone who has followed us
at our patreon page by becoming super sexy
rejects we've been getting so many patrons
due to the fact that we've been covering so
many movies full-length Reaction watch the
laundry sink with your own copy of Mario available
for them over there and also we cover several
things exclusively with reaction Heights and
watch songs included for our patrons alrighty
guys let's get to it
ah yes it's already working on me
animation looks great yeah
Spartans all right
so cinematic it's a little bit cool in 3D
I bet open the gates or die locked Gates
[Music]
[Laughter] [Music]
[Laughter] house oh brought ice to a lava
fight a taste of our Fury
[Laughter] I do not oh for penguins
that is threatening it's Epic no
the star yes
oh no oh
nice oh there's a star yeah okay finally found
it and now no one can stop me yes I've collected
a bunch of real brothers
on the brothers
Mario Brothers oh my God Easter eggs Galore
damn I am so
quick is it too much too much it's a perfect
nice oh it's got the colors of the original
Mario is that the original voice actor I bet
if it is
The Wrecking Crew guy tell me have you even
gotten one call since you left me to start
your dumb company as a matter of fact Spike
we have nice you're a joke and you always
will be no he's gonna prove himself in this
movie he's gonna become a badass a chosen
one that game inspired Wreck-It Ralph he's
come on you know you can't be scared all the
time and you'd be surprised
GameCube [Laughter]
that's great you called us because we can
be there and we can fix it right away okay
that's so perfect Brothers yes I love the
GameCube love that is resurfaced lately
[Music] okay that's also in Guardians of the
Galaxy yeah wherever so strides Chris Pratt
boy the Beastie Boys are not far behind
oh that's great nicely done
oh that's fantastic sorry
yeah the up and downs oh yes right down the
pole oh the princess is in another castle
that was fun
[Music] what have you done Luigi what Francis
is here
kill the dog
[Music]
ah super shower Brothers
no
[Laughter]
whoa jeez love the way this is shot yeah and
the textures are gorgeous
no it won't
all comes down to one wrench every time
oh [Music]
no jeez laughs
great plungers
Star Fox oh that's the movie I want to make
boy we are very close to fixing this somebody
else somebody say Brooklyn save Brooklyn save
Brooklyn this
ah duck hunt where the little duck logo yeah
I'm sure we've already missed like 20 Easters
I should have brought my duck hunt gun
Mario
yes down the warp tube this is a gorgeous
looking movie
yeah a lot of the environments look real
oh boy [Music] come on you're below the Mario
no
[Applause]
dude
what is this place laughs well if you're impressed
by that just get ready man you gotta whirl
the tubes ahead of you Luigi
hold on to your mustache
bye Frost enter the Stargate
I'm telling you nothing can hurt us as long
as we're together sure oh no the pie Frost
it's also like a little Doctor Who Doctor
Mario
's around here somewhere please pleased to
meet you I'm toad
Um Kingdom now that is a cruel twist of fate
that is what he hates see last time I saw
him he was falling through a pipe it was foggy
and I believe there was brother is landed
in the dark lands about control uh-oh why'd
you say that name [Music] good score hang
on Luigi
wow Mario you've adjusted to this magical
Wonderland really fast oh is that a Yoshi
it's like a little ghost turtle yeah Turtle
oh or skelet turtle
oh
I could watch this all day I'm saying bring
me that Luigi's Mansion movie
oh my God please do a Luigi's Mansion move
how cool and visually striking this is yeah
like we're in Resident Evil now Castlevania
yes chanterelle
you just have to blow into It Antiques I love
it they're all 8-bit [Music] love it love
it and they're good at using the motifs but
still having it feel like a real movie score
oh cool yes
[Music]
how would you navigate this just like the
sewer here we are
we on it's like the N64 version here we go
oh hey I need to see the princess what princess
I never heard of any princess oh wait I did
a princess though is in another Castle
it's not falling for that
I don't like it [Music] what do you guys um
what do you want to eat anything anything
your hearts desire nice
counsel your attention Bowser has found the
Superstar and is headed toward our kingdom
no their Mad King doesn't make alliances the
Kongs will never agree I can convince him
I'll leave for the jungle Kingdom in the morning
that's gonna be cool
open make fun of me all you want but you were
gonna help me find my brother please okay
let's see what you're made of that's quite
a negotiation if I was cutting through every
ounce of fat yes no debate whoa
nice looks like the Lego version I was gonna
say where's the Lego Mario movie [Music] it's
like a training course you can finish this
watch and learn
way to go Peach
wow oh she doesn't need a protector the action
visuals are gorgeous
as a fan of my existence [Music] hey I love
it look out of uh Mario too That was supposed
to do that with the power-ups they give us
special abilities
really go on eat it make you big and strong
time to trip out man
whoa whoa dang
[Music] oh we've all been there buddy oh yeah
when you get hit you lose the power come on
needle drops 1980s worst
yep
yep having sense memory flashbacks
come on get the top don't look down I'll come
on Mario we young journey ahead of us mustache
but I didn't make it make it you almost did
no one gets it right away I was not good at
it worse than you you're full of crap lady
I grew up here okay now you're just trying
to make me feel better no is it working a
little bit yeah yeah ah YouTube
[Music] Goombas references my Army Cooper
Goombas whatever those things are I will ask
their princess to marry me in a fairy tale
wedding okay
doesn't she hate you of course she hates me
but that makes me love her all the more her
heart-shaped bangs the way she floats in the
breeze that's interesting what if she says
no then I will power up with this star and
destroy the Mushroom Kingdom prepare yourselves
for the best wedding ever
I guess that's why you kidnap a princess
hahaha
Baby Mario I love that they even kind of brought
back this design
[Music] will stop uh booty he's not important
you're important Mario you're coming with
us
jump in the cannon Yoshi's hey Russell oh
my God a Jack Black song [Music] this is something
von Koopa
I understand [Music] I love it they let him
do this HSP just peaches [Laughter] I was
about to ask if they let him improv this
why'd you interrupt no a mustachioed human
has arrived in the Mushroom Kingdom the princess
has been training him they are up to something
sire [__] what yes Ludwig von Koopa where
did he come from
look in the mirror you'll have nothing to
worry about I know that I'm not threatened
oh Jack Black is great yeah I just finished
Kung Fu Panda 3 so it's kind of fun just switching
to this an hour later yeah don't worry we're
going to save him that Firepower
nice
took me in raised me like one of their own
you're clearly from Earth your parents are
probably so worried maybe you're from my world
there's a huge Universe out there with a lot
of galaxies yes Super Mario Galaxy yeah maybe
you just gotta go through that pipe Peach
and your parents yeah I mean it seems like
you could easily trace it back to
what is your name
Luigi Mario there's a human traveling with
my fiancee do you know him no like they twirled
somebody else's mustache do you think I know
every human being with a mustache wearing
an identical outfit with a how with the letter
of his first name on it because I don't know
[Music]
since it's fine camera attractive hey [Music]
where am I foreign what is that star's name
[Music] Lumia There's No Escape only hope
is the sweet relief of death
I thought that star can can get out of there
I don't know problem it seems like
we are here to see the king follow me
time for a little Diddy Kong race is that
Funky Kong
[Music] this is cool this is really cool
ah great reference
oh wow yeah I get the Boost [Music]
yes they got the updated Mario Kart in here
[Music]
interesting voice choice we're not leaving
without your army defeat defeat my son great
rig GS let's go let's get it going thank you
Fred Armisen that's Fred Armisen yeah I think
so
wow so many Kongs
awesome [Applause] here we go DK rap [Applause]
dude okay Donkey Kong okay simmer down I said
simmer down
[Applause]
[Music]
ah okay guess you're not getting my Army oh
God
is this what you came for you
it is on like a Donkey Kong unlike me
oh nice you're about to pick on someone your
own size it's a different kind of mushroom
yeah yeah it's tiny yep
[Music] [Laughter] it actually works really
well yeah yeah
the platforms yes yeah oh that's cool barrels
the Donkey Kong arcade classic yes oh here
we go oh come on
he's just a human how can he withstand the
pain
that's right
[Music]
good fake out [Music] catsuit I'm a cat cool
awesome uh put some respect on that cat suit
[Music] take that as a yes [Music]
Mario Mario we've located Bowser's ship he's
gonna ride private the Mushroom Kingdom by
Sundown we're gonna need cots [Music] yes
I normally love Fred Armisen but I'm not a
big fan of the choice of the voice he could
be older and crankier go I love how to structure
this to get to references 64 on that shoulder
plate
oh yeah
it's like an Iron Man reference
the motorcycle
toad I usually play as toad yeah man get that
Speed and Agility I hear you to the Mushroom
Kingdom and the biggest fight Our Lives
oh what's the shortcut gonna be so it's not
gonna be a race nah well that we know of Princess
Peach here we are I guess love really makes
a guy come out of his shell [Laughter] we
have found
for their secret s oh they think they can
surprise me huh two can play at that game
Mad Mario Fury Road that's gonna have Anya
Taylor Joyce Furious that's right Easter eggs
within Easter eggs [Music]
the rainbow the Rainbow Road
[Music]
we don't drive on rainbows what are you gonna
tell me next that the turtles aren't evil
and usually pets no way back on the Brooklyn
I'll buy you a turtle hey you like the turtles
um
[Music]
you know I would often play as Bowser in uh
Mario Kart so this is fitting yeah come on
get a spiked one
bananas no
no this really is like Mad Max Mad Max Rainbow
Road
God it's so hard driving now jump off one
ramp and fall onto another and cut everybody
two laps
whoa [Applause]
that would be absolutely terrifying
gnarly Mario drift
throw the show
oh damn peachy we whooping ass
oh my God toad
[Music] holy moly this is how you princess
[Music] oh God
you never don't want to quit Mario
we're just murdering characters hey man they're
just Koopas their lives mean nothing you me
what oh blue shell blue shell it's inescapable
it's a cool sci-fi shot I feel like it should
have been the Red Shell because a blue shell
usually goes to the front of the race line
yeah whereas a red shell you can specifically
Target it clearly the creators need to study
up with their Mario Kart
oh no save him we need to spit off yeah in
all the spin-offs
not bad you saved my life yeah well I won't
tell anyone good please don't [Laughter] this
is great delivery
I was scared yeah and the lighting and the
water like [Music]
yeah these moving shots are incredible princess
we lost the
SE
Wowie [Music] I stole this star for us I guess
God love really makes a guy come out of his
shell oh no buddy no I like this motive I
would never marry you maybe you see there
oh I'll marry you just don't hurt my toads
that's how you want to get a yes just marry
him what's a big deal it's your job you're
a woman it's like there's no other humans
here how do you even know what the concept
of a human is [Laughter]
where you allowed be ritualistically sacrifice
yay well at least your brother isn't gonna
die because of you at least you're not gonna
die with your dad thinking you're a joke yeah
well my dad thinks I'm a joke too yeah well
your dad's right just just leave me alone
I've never met your dad but he sounds brilliant
just go over the corner and smash some stuff
smash
monkeys I think Donkey Kong is my favorite
huh [Music] that was convenient
wow that was a gorgeous shot
that's a nice detail
oh King Boo you really thought I'd marry you
kinda I'd never marry a Monster ice ice [Music]
they gotta be up there
no [Applause] [Music] come on fire suit
fire Kong yes
oh
[Music]
yes yes
love the leaf my favorite suit from Mario
three
[Music] oh no dude Peach is so badass in this
movie is that murder
oh Luigi no no save my boy
Donkey Kong more than just a Smasher that
would be a terrifying scenario yeah hold on
oh no [Music] Mario
I told you see the squares were together everything
is gonna be okay oh I wish they were together
for more of the movie yeah really
[Music] oh that jealousy breakthrough with
pure rage
the Mushroom Kingdom oh no no oh no
what are you gonna do Mario you know just
hop on top of it real quick
foreign
[Music]
oh sure no totally
send it to Earth make him a pet
[Music] oh
all right just out into the circuits of time
whoa oh no this pancake's good though to save
Brooklyn you gotta first put Brooklyn in a
lot more danger yes
huh
Brooklyn oh Mario
whoa damn when there's something strange in
the neighborhood
grab it power up Mario power up you little
Italian man
wow oh my God his strength is impeccable ruined
my wedding I was finally gonna be happy where
are you now you will suffer oh the luck card
thing on the side of the building yeah Peach
come out
and do the whole thing in your Italian accent
leave him alone Mario you just don't know
when to quit that's his problem themes [Music]
no that's mine come on Marion power up thanks
you just gave him a boost yeah seriously
oh my man
I would get the star oh
awesome that's pretty cool that's pretty cool
oh
[Music]
thank you [Music]
and the Run
that's right Mom and Dad yo
Mamma Mia [Music]
love it [Music]
right into his own nose
kick it ass now that's what I call a Mario
Party
that's it for the Super Mario Brothers [Applause]
you guys
[Music]
I love how they have the original guy there
yeah it's almost as if you could have been
in the movie nah it's impossible which has
way too much
Guardians too is that Captain Falcon's car
on the on the wall Falco punch
[Music]
all right well done
Mario
now that's a happy ending or is it because
everything's over now and all that's left
is you and the infinite voice
Boop
foreign
well done well done well done all right I'm
assuming there's going to be a post-credits
scene gotta be at least five
all right well might as well start reviewing
it now sure thing review Starts Now and then
we raise our volume up and we freak out when
a scene starts all right review starts in
three two one and John take it away ah this
was very very much fun I mean you know I I
had heard varying things from people about
like oh how the story moves and yes like the
story itself is straight to the point as you
said no fat on it but it was super fun super
colorful and just like beautifully realized
in terms of just like the designs the textures
the lighting the camera work the actual choice
to make it feel like real camera work and
stuff like that all the different uh characters
they chose to include out of the pantheon
uh yeah I mean I think there's certainly ways
they can build on this they can you know make
an even more satisfying Super Mario Bros movie
especially when there's more Luigi for my
money but uh you know for for where we are
in video game movies and stuff like that uh
this was super duper fun and uh and yeah I
would be happy to see this on a big screen
at some point yeah yeah I mean I feel like
this was a there was uh uh a good it was a
good movie as a a good movie but there was
a great movie that they could have made out
of it 100 and that's the part of me that I'm
like oh I could see the great movie here and
like you don't really have to change anything
about like who the characters are necessarily
it's just it could have they could have just
taken their time a little bit more and flesh
more things out it needed a little bit of
that Phil Lord and Chris Miller touch I think
yeah I don't think I did myself any favors
just finishing Kung Fu Panda 3 which is the
weakest of the Kung Fu Panda movies uh still
love that movie uh at the same time like probably
shouldn't have just watched that movie right
after which does do a lot more of like character
building flushing scenes out and fleshing
out the characters to get to the point let's
put this up the audio up Mario Luigi and a
donkey come true Princess Peach at the end
of life I'll make you mine yes yes awesome
awesome has he performed this life
no little guy you're here
oh
damn yeah and like I think the voice over
work was pretty great I have a couple of mixed
opinions about uh the direction they took
with Chris Pratt's Mario uh because I thought
like the overall Choice was good let's just
start with the rattle off the good ones right
I don't want to be too cynical here at the
very top because the way I would overall packages
like I understand this movie for kids and
I think it's a kids movie it's pretty Rock
Solid like it's a solid kids movie I could
totally see this being the kind of movie that
parents love their children to go witness
and you can even put on the TV multiple times
like for children it's fantastic and I guess
the reason why I was making the Kung Fu Panda
comparison was because I was like oh I'm used
to you know like in the animated medium of
like movies that are like really for the whole
families that even as an adult you can really
appreciate it so that's so I thought there
were like elements lacking in storytelling
but as a fan of the Mario games yeah no the
the references and the Easter eggs and all
the Nostalgia elements were totally working
for me whenever they were on screen because
there were some beautiful animation in here
from beginning to end and so many I'm sure
we missed plenty of references that were like
in the backgrounds or whatever maybe some
that were front and center that we didn't
catch uh however like then they did bring
a lot of that visually to life it was it was
gorgeous and it does play on that nostalgic
feeling so as a Mario fan I was satisfied
with a lot of that in regards to doing that
especially compared to like the you know Mario
live action movie that came in a couple days
decades ago this was this was amazing and
I thought Bowser was great right I mean I
think uh I love the choice of having me in
love with peach yeah no I thought that was
a nice I mean like why else I guess would
you be kidnapping this princess over and over
and over again if not for some kind of political
game then for love and uh yeah I thought that
was a really fun way to just give Bowser some
kind of flavor that you could latch on to
and I I would agree pretty much with everything
you just said it's like there are those moments
especially where like Mario and Peach are
learning about each other or they're bonding
like you know there's not really any you you
don't come to a movie like this for like character
development but there are a couple key moments
where I was like yeah if you let this breathe
and you didn't like Rush directly past the
meat of this little scene we could have something
that's like touching and that yeah endears
you beyond the functionality of being you
know just a a recreation of all the you know
major tenets of Mario and Donkey Kong and
whatever else but it had moments where you
could see that it's like it had a heart but
it could have used more of a beating heart
everything about it was there was there was
constantly something there like oh this chemistry
of a Donkey Kong and their the competition
and the bickering like oh yeah a lot of this
is a great great outline no totally solid
outline here but the the lead into a lot of
things and the building of a lot of things
just could have been way more fleshed out
and you could just see like there's a there's
a greater more emotionally fulfilling and
funnier movie too yeah because if you play
up a lot of more of the emotions and like
play into more like with Cranky Kong and Donkey
Kong then some of the jokes would even work
a lot stronger as well so there was a lot
of opportunities that I thought they could
have made for again like I said like a strong
just a stronger overall movie like Voice work
was great Peach was as awesome as I expected
her to be I thought Anya Taylor Joy did an
excellent job craved more Luigi because I
think Charlie day was perfect casting for
Luigi yeah absolutely perfect and and the
opportunity to hear them together because
I really like their you know back and forth
but you know like because Luigi is so relegated
through so much of this like I did find myself
wanting a bit more of that because I don't
know like the chemistry and uh I don't know
I feel like growing up you know everybody
has if you grew up on Mario games like I was
a Luigi kid I I usually was like if given
the opportunity I was like yeah I won't be
Luigi and so like you know you want I think
that Rapport and I mean you don't get like
a Wario or a Waluigi in this but you you know
you want to feel like the Mario brothers are
both well represented here yeah and yeah it's
like you do have a great choice in Charlie
day and you know I know Chris Pratt has received
so much of the attention good and bad for
this um and yeah it's like I thought he was
nice I like that they account for the Italian
accents and the commercial and stuff like
that like that's kind of cheeky and fun the
rest of the time Mario kind of reminded me
a bit of of Mark Wahlberg but not in a way
that was like bad or distracting uh I I did
think his performance lacked an energy though
sure everyone else really even with a choice
like Fred armisen's who I wasn't a big fan
of the choice
[Music] I want to lay down a prediction but
I don't want to ruin it if I'm right I'll
do that yep
Godzilla 99 ending yeah good tease I was like
we didn't get I mean we saw some Yoshi's maybe
they shouldn't have shown any Yoshi yeah well
that would have been more exciting I think
if we didn't see I feel like Yoshi if there's
no Yoshi anything short of having Yoshi be
an actual character in an actual you know
like psychic Steed to Mario I think is gonna
cause people to be like where's Yoshi but
uh back to Chris Pratt I did I mean I'd love
to see more I'd love to actually see Yoshi
in a sequel but to Chris Pratt yeah there
was I was like oh The Voice choice is not
bad I actually thought the voice Choice worked
and worked for this movie um I was like yeah
okay yeah we didn't have to shy away from
that in the marketing it worked for this movie
however as the film kept going and maybe it's
because I wasn't truly everything was just
always like on a cute level but lack substance
to me and I I wasn't like truly emotionally
invested in Mario like I was on board for
the adventure because I'm a Mario fan and
I like seeing like Mario Kart come to life
and all that uh but I wasn't like you know
strongly rooting for Mario here yeah and maybe
it had something to do with my emotional investment
in him I did think Chris Pratt's uh Direction
was surprisingly like restrained for an animated
movie yeah it's funny this does seem to be
one of those things where I can feel a lot
of different choices being made among the
voice cast I I like most everybody to some
degree that they got but the two characters
that I think were at the right energy level
for the pace of the movie and just the way
the movie chose to yeah kind of gloss over
you know like the emotional beats and themes
are touched upon in like singular little moments
and then you move on so it's like Donkey Kong
and Bowser were the two voices Jack Black
and Seth Rogen that felt like perfectly attuned
to what we're getting as well as what the
characters are as well and Charlie Day yeah
absolutely only only wanting for the fact
that he just doesn't get a lot of time to
do his thing um but yeah I would agree it's
like the movie moves at such a pace and I
think I remarked early on when Louis G's in
the forest at first I was like oh this is
kind of intense but as things go on it mostly
derives intensity from just being such a fast-paced
movie and having such beautiful visuals because
yeah it's like this whole thing about Mario
not wanting to be some kind of joke to his
dad and uh Donkey Kong and identifying with
that and them you know like it really kind
of fell into that trap of like okay we established
a character conflict and we're wrapping it
up right away because we gotta move along
and we're not gonna do a scene about it we're
just gonna kind of acknowledge it and then
have the updated character beat and move on
yeah and so I feel like a movie yeah it really
was and I felt like Chris Pratt especially
almost seemed like he wanted to go for something
that had like a little more feeling in it
and I was like dude you're you're getting
drowned out a bit in the cacophony and luckily
you know this movie isn't really concerned
that much with that stuff so it's not like
a big deal but at the same time it's noticeable
it's a little noticeable uh yeah I mean you
know like a lot of peaches stuff that they
give her like I thought I knew Taylor Joy
did a good job but like so much of her character
is pretty much action lines directing where
the plot's going yeah I think the storytelling
it did at the end of the day it's like the
the thing that kept this movie alive was certain
voice performances and consistent beautiful
animation throughout yeah that energy yeah
so just to me it kept the movie at like a
fine level to me but the storytelling was
the part where as it really it just bugs me
strongly because it's like it's right there
yeah yeah it's right there but they don't
give you I I don't really care about I'm not
worried about Peach and the Peril there for
the Mushroom Kingdom it's kind of like you
just like get it out of the way yeah no it
feels everything the conflicts feel requisite
except and and they don't even really give
you any time to you know Peach isn't gonna
marry Bowser but I feel like that is the closest
we get to some kind of interesting actual
plot Dynamic yeah is watching how the whole
marriage thing is is going to unfold and then
pretty quick it's like no I was never going
to marry you and we're just back to fighting
and you know it's it's fine but yeah there's
so much here that's interesting and it's contained
within this one movie that you wouldn't need
a sequel to explore well I I think too you
know I could already hear like certain comments
coming in of being like what do you guys watch
just wanted a cute fun movie and that's what
we got and yeah and I will say it's a cute
fun movie that's a hundred percent right I
do think though that we are also in a day
and age where we get a lot of animated movies
that are like truly expensive with a big voice
cast like this yes where they have something
that is truly emotionally engaging and you
feel the stakes throughout and like you know
Chris Pratt was like in The Lego Movie you
know like we have these at these actors in
here and it's it's the it's a Mario movie
so I do think that it could have been more
than especially when you are presenting the
pieces for it to make it more than just passable
kids movie entertainment and that's only where
I'm coming from on it well and let's see well
and then you're aiming this not only at kids
you're aiming this at people who grew up in
the 80s and 90s who had all that stuff and
who would probably also want a little bit
more oomph in their story not your only only
aiming it towards them but like there's so
many 80s needle drops and things that are
clearly only for or or mainly for that side
of the audience that includes us that would
want yeah something a little more to sink
your teeth into alongside you know like the
Mario games aren't always the deepest in terms
of emotional plotting obviously but you know
we all have an emotional connection to that
and I think you want to replicate something
akin to that with a movie like this yeah because
they had all the they had all the points there
of you know Mario is is not uh looked his
career Pursuits and his Endeavors or not look
fondly upon by his family uh he feels like
he's not good enough and you know Luigi rely
so much on Mario protecting him and then he's
if they don't even really lean too much into
the fish out of water quality with Mario and
even with the training segment I'm like oh
we could have really done something here where
you really feel like you got to root for him
or Donkey Kong feeling like he's not good
enough and his father his father the way his
father views him and then we could have really
had a strong truly strong bonding moment over
that with them finding that kinship and Rapport
due to feeling like they're not good enough
and they got to overcome this together you
know like and the Peril could have really
felt real or not real but you know actually
tangible to the point where you're like yeah
go get him yeah you want some that some of
that emotional swell yeah so I I did miss
I I did I would be lying if I said like I
I wish we I really it does it does leave me
thinking about that because everything else
that I'm like an admiration appreciative of
I feel like I definitely expressed during
this reaction of the video like I feel like
I expressed that throughout the best things
about it are very immediate yeah not to say
that they're all surface level but they are
immediate for the most part though it's a
pretty service level yeah and I I think a
sequel though could improve upon it you know
like I I I think out of the video game movies
I'd still prefer the Sonic ones uh like this
looks better this is more visually impressive
but I still prefer the Sonic movies Sonic
surprises you with heart and I think that
is the thing is like you could look at Super
Mario and be like we're not coming for a plot
or or things like that but I'm like every
animated movie especially of this variety
certainly benefits from people coming out
and going well I didn't expect to be moved
or to care yeah exactly this went above and
beyond my expectations and I mean this they
have so many things going for them and so
much so many resources clearly that they I
don't think it would have been too taxing
to go above and beyond in those departments
yeah no but I think on the on the surface
stuff that all does work though like the music
is great I love how it was a constant Riff
on the a lot of the variations of the Mario
themes throughout the game not just the main
tune uh and I I thought actually king of Michael
key as toad was good yeah I enjoyed his his
performance as well and the the Mario Kart
sequences the action sequences uh because
a lot of them are are a lot of the sequences
to what was cool about the references is that
it didn't just purely rely on references in
their visual action scenes or their moving
camera moments like at the beginning in Brooklyn
or or when Donkey Kong's fighting Mario like
you'll pick up on it if you're familiar with
it uh but it doesn't rely on just like hey
cool I know that like you would I would still
find it cool even if I wasn't aware of what
they're referencing yeah you know yeah they
just make the world feel alive enough and
they give you at least that one info dump
on power-ups and I think that's most of what
you need the rest of it you know I think making
Mario a bit of a fish out of water and introducing
you to this world is a good thing because
it also hearkens back to being a beginner
at a game and also it you know gives us an
inroad to the Hero Journey well if you're
doing an animated I think they could have
really played up him being like a true Fish
Out of Water because he's just kind of like
Oh weird yeah yeah he used to be like freaking
out yeah especially in a place surrounded
by his least favorite food yeah yeah like
giant lava you know floating Bowser head from
the sky like there's a lot of horror in this
that doesn't really get acknowledged heavily
in a character sense um I like the songs that
they have with Bowser that's on the credits
that uh Jack Black was able to write uh write
it uh I I think they could definitely do a
great sequel though that's the thing is I
I do feel like this is a step in the right
direction and this they could make a great
sequel out of this and I mean down to see
a Donkey Kong movie too because I think I
think uh Seth rogans was I did not expect
to be saying that I thought I would just only
maybe some people feel this way for like I
would love a Luigi's Mansion spin-off um but
I thought Seth Rogen was actually they really
seem like they've I felt like they were trying
to fit what CR I feel like they had to work
with Chris Pratt to fit him into it sure whereas
they kind of mold the Donkey Kong around Seth
Rogen it felt like the perfect blend yeah
it was surprisingly natural it felt like a
nice halfway where it's like okay Seth Rogen's
got to do a little bit of not being just Seth
Rogen but also this suits the character well
enough that like yeah when he does his signature
laugh like it it was more it's surprisingly
works yeah totally and it's not just I only
see and hear Seth Rogen no it was the one
it was it was one of the few characters where
I really was just thinking about Donkey Kong
yeah like like a lot of the time I was aware
and and sometimes you know because I was excited
or whatever else you know about different
voice performances or because you know you're
examining them to see how they are but he
really managed to just kind of disappear into
the character in an odd way yeah he's one
of the main he's one of the characters in
the Kung Fu Panda movies as well but every
time he's spoken those I was aware of Seth
Rogan but but here I I got lost in the Donkey
Kong performance I thought that was really
great I like the the way they decided to ride
him like I'm not familiar with what the Donkey
Kong story actually goes like and they teased
Diddy Kong in here uh I I Diddy Kong was my
favorite to play as so I would love to see
Diddy Kong uh return that's right Diddy Kong
Racing that that game I totally forgot I read
like that so many times totally forgot about
your video back in the day I yeah totally
even when you said it I didn't even remember
it until like right now this one like oh yeah
Diddy Kong Racing I forgot him yeah okay man
classic you're like flying [__] yeah yeah
totally tough it wasn't an easy game for me
no no in some ways I remember being a bit
more of a challenge to pick up than something
like a Mario Kart yeah I definitely thought
it was and I mean you know I've always found
Donkey Kong a bit more challenging than the
arcade Mario games yeah because it's one of
those movies where it's a fish out of water
and they come to this magical land and then
anybody you know you're kind of like semi-chosen
one to be the one to save it the one the least
unexpected person and uh I wish I wish I kind
of cared a little bit more about Mario and
I wish I cared a little bit more about the
perilous situation these toads and Peach was
in oh yeah cause when he shows up it's pretty
much just like hey you're another human oh
you showed up right where I'm going on this
adventure I guess come along yeah even for
her that could have been played up a little
bit more of like what is the human world like
and trying to discover it and yeah yeah I
just felt like it could be so many options
if you use an extra 20 minutes just to flush
out these scenes just to make the scenes just
to enhance the scenes just 20 more minutes
could have like then you could have added
on like a couple more minutes to a lot of
these scenes and then bam you would have had
a much stronger a much stronger film that
resonates a lot more yeah but hey as a kids
movie does the job gets the job done yeah
because I think when you talk in the Optics
of family films that's where the lines get
blurry because you go family films that encompasses
because like yeah it's a film for the family
but then there's like a film the whole family
I feel like this this is a perhaps something
that flirts with that line between being a
kids movie versus being a family movie like
I feel like they went to the kids movie route
for their actual storytelling yeah and they
had a lot of family movie themes yeah that
they just didn't really explore yeah because
yeah exactly it's like pitching it towards
the whole family because there's there's inevitably
going to be a bunch that you know the older
audience is going to catch and is going to
be coming looking for and I feel like yeah
speaking to that would be a benefit the next
time around but like you said too they've
laid themselves a strong Foundation which
is a good thing yeah there was a great movie
there that could have existed but uh right
now we got a really pretty good one we gotta
we got a good one that delivers on the visuals
uh that one would want and maybe you got exactly
what you wanted that's the thing I got exactly
what I expected yes I did too and and but
I didn't but I but what Pete what was poking
at me was oh but the great one is is wants
to come out yeah it's right there that tastes
I can see it and if that great one wasn't
there yeah like like waiting to come out of
its pipe then I probably wouldn't have said
it yeah totally um but yeah anyway guys what
did you think about the Mario Brothers movie
did you overall love it did it did it uh meet
up to all the expectations for you comment
all the Easter eggs we missed leave it all
in the comment boxes below uh you can subscribe
leave a like or if you're mad at us for having
an opinion that's fine uh Hey listen to the
paper
David Gandy I'd like to think of you as someone
who would be a great plumber yes you would
oh I surprisingly feel like you actually would
know what you're doing I suck when it comes
to fixing my toilet really not good at it
every time I'm trying to look up videos and
usually it's the simplest solution but I feel
like I can count on you you would probably
just burst through a pipe yourself show up
and fix it or yourself and I would love that
about you I could see you also being the third
brother get Coy out of here you could be the
third brother here at the rejection right
you would be our Sage wise brother who keeps
us on the straight and narrow and teaches
us everything we know about life and then
I could also see you being like Bowser wanting
to marry Terror Erickson you pervert territory
David candy David David candy did you like
this movie David to you not like do you wanting
more and going out and getting your like Super
Mario toys and then photographing them in
Epic ways you're also a hardcore Christian
tell us the Christian metaphors you caught
in this movie yeah yeah well I mean clearly
Peach is uh is Mary Magdalene Mario's Jesus
Marias Jesus and uh you know Bowser is Todd
is Todd toad is John the Baptist yeah definitely
it is yeah exactly I think we got it and then
you know Peter Luigi can be Simon Peter who
starts the church there you go four shout
outs in one you are the Jesus of our patreon
page thanks for being here David
foreign